[Musique]
le grand oral des candidats à la
présidentielle devant l'Assemblée des
départements de France un événement que
vous avez pu d'ailleurs suivre ce matin
en direct sur les chaînes parlementaires
que propose-t-il pour cet échon
territoriale qui a failli disparaître du
millefeuille sous le quinquena de
François Hollande quel avenir quelle
compét élément de réponse avec Quentin
calm ils avaient 4 heur pour plancher
sur la décentralisation les six
principaux candidats où leurs
représentants passaient leur grand oral
ce matin face à des dizaines de
présidents de département parmi les plus
attendus Emmanuel Macron qui s'est
exprimé sous le regard attentif de son
parrain en politique Gérard Colomb le
maire de Lyon Lyon cité en exemple par
le candidat du mouvement en marche
proposant de réduire d'un/art le nombre
de départements pour les remplacer par
les métropole sur ces territoires où des
métropoles fortes sont constituées il
est évident qu'il faut progressivement
et c'est l'objectif pour moi du prochain
quinquena et bien en faire des vrais
pôles de prospérité et de croissance qui
pensent au niveau du département et qui
pourront prendre en charge les
attributions des conseils départementaux
réduire le nombre de départements c'est
aussi la proposition de Nicolas duup
pooignant pour en avoir 70 ou 80 en
France mais pour autant le candidat de
Debout la France a défendu les
départements se montrant très incisif
face aux membres de l'ADF je suis très
surpris que vous ne vous défendiez pas
davantage
dénonçant un millefeuille territoriale
il propose de supprimer les conseils
régionaux et de faire revenir certaines
compétences à l'état supprimer les
régions c'est aussi la vision de Marine
Le Pen représentée par son directeur de
campagne David rashlin croons donc
profondément au tripti commune des
partement état que Marine propose de
renforcer dans cette campagne
présidentielle et parmi les propositions
plus de proportionnel des référendums
locaux ou encore la lutte contre la
fraude aux allocations plus de servic
public et des moyens au département
pierre y Colomba s'exprimait au nom de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon profitant de cet oral
pour dénoncer les politiques d'austérité
l'aménagement du territoire le
développement des ruralités sont pour
lui des leviers de la politique de
relance économique qui nous permettra de
sortir du purgatoire économique dans
lequel le pays s'est enfermé depuis 10
ans même discours sur la dépense
publique pour Benoît Hamont qui a
longuement défendu la nouvelle version
de son revenu universel qui englobera le
RSA le RSA une des prérogatives du
département je défends donc une vision
totalement renouvelée de la solidarité
car je ne crois pas que l'urgence se
soit de pointer du doigt les personnes
les plus fragiles dans notre société en
leur imposant des contreparties ou en
les excluant davantage l'urgence c'est
de lutter contre la pauvreté dans ce
pays et contre le non recours à la
solidarité qui est malheureusement bien
plus important que la fraude un candidat
qui prône la stabilité de l'organisation
territoriale pas de nouvell réformes
dans l'immédias François Fillon est
d'accord sur ce point baisse des
dotations augmentation du temps de
travail et diminu
nair son CR plus de liberté pour les
collectivités si les départements si des
départements veulent fusionner pourquoi
ne le feril pas si dans une région des
élus veulent expérimenter le conseiller
territorial et bien je proposerai qu'on
leur rendonne la possibilité une matinée
entière pour débattre de
décentralisation cet événement aura
ainsi permis au candidats de développer
leur vision de la France et des
territoires
et on ouvre le débat avec mes invités
sur ce plateau Jean-René leer bonsoir
merci d'être sur ce plateau vous êtes le
président du conseil départemental du
Nord vous êtes plutôt classé divers
droite merci d'être avec nous Stéphane
Troussel est également sur ce plateau
bonsoir président socialiste du
département de la scène Saint-Denis vous
êtes trésorier adjoint de l'ADF
l'Assemblée des départements de France
et puis Patrick leidek bonsoir vous êtes
chargé de recherche auocnrs spécialiste
de ces questions de décentralisation
première question pour vous Jean-René le
serer vous avez assisté hein ce matin on
vient de le voir à ce grand oral des
candidats est-ce que ils ont finalement
répondu à vos attentes oui et non si
vous voulez bon tout le monde il est
beau tout le monde il est gentil
c'est-à-dire que j'ai jamais rarement vu
autant de départementaliste en si peu de
place j'ai deux candidats qui ont
annoncé qu'ils allaient supprimer la
région par exemple les intercommunalités
à leur place je me méfierait beaucoup
alors le département c'est la proximité
c'est la solidarité territoriale c'est
la solidarité humaine pas question de
toucher au département et puis il va ça
va très mal les départements donc ils
l'ont tous dit il y a pas eu un seul qui
a levé la main pour défendre les
politiques qui ont été menées et qui
font effectivement qu'en matière
d'allocation individuelle de solidarité
on n'est pas bien quand même pas plus la
SA Sainté d'ailleurs que le département
du Nord avec les restes à charge du RSA
de la pas et de la PCH et puis bon il y
a eu quelques propositions intéressantes
et une matinée qui n'était pas du temps
perdu mais de là à dire qu'on a eu des
réponses non d'as pour qu'il a des
réponses faut qu'il y a un dialogue ça a
été une série de monologue Stéphane
trousal est-ce que vous partagez cette
analyse est-ce que c'était des discours
finalement électoralistes on a plutôt
flatté cet échelant territorial qu le
département oui on peut voir les choses
de cette manière mais je je pense
qu'aussi enfin moi j'essaie de voir les
choses positivement je suis un perpétuel
optimiste je pense qu'on on on sort
peut-être d'une période au moment où le
pays s'interroge
doute on sort d'une période finalement
où la mise en cause du département
justement qui est la sol la la
collectivité qui organise principalement
depuis 2004 à travers le versement des
trois allocations de solidarité et bien
le l'accompagnement des plus fragiles
euh les les personnes privées d'emploi
les les personnes en situation de
handicap les les les personnes âgées au
moment où on va connaître une transition
démographique la place de nos aînés la
question du vieillissement et donc
reconnaître que cette collectivité dont
c'est la mission principale et bien
finalement euh elle sert peut-être à
quelque chose et il va peut-être falloir
régler sa situation d'autant plus que on
a créé des grandes régions ou de fait en
créant des grandes régions ça a un peu
sauvé le département et du coup et bien
oui la question du financement des
moyens des départements se pose à
nouveau très fortement ouais alors
Patrick Le liidc sur la question de la
réforme territoriale on a quand même
entendu les candidats ce matin dire
qu'il fallait arrêter hein finalement
ces multiple réforme on avait même pas
le temps d'appliquer que ça soit la loi
nôre ou la loi sur les collectivités on
appelle un peu à une sorte de
stabilisation justement territoriale
est-ce que le département qui avait un
peu sauvé sa peau he sous le quinquena
de François Hollande est de nouveau
menacé dans les propositions des
candidats à venir selon vous je crois
pas qu'il soit directement menacé dans
dans dans l'immédiia en tout cas dans sa
généralité le Pr manuel Macron propose
d'en supprimer un/art d'ici 2022 he oui
mais enfin ça ça n'est ça n'est pas ça
n'est pas encore fait hein volontariat
voilà et donc et donc donc là-dessus je
pense que c'est ces propositions en fait
elle se situe dans le prolongement de de
l'application de la loi nôtre qui euh
disons permet euh au département euh de
déléguer un certain nombre de
compétences euh aux métropoes pour
autant que les métropoles euh soient
candidates à exercer ces ses compétences
or elles ne le sont pas toutes et et
donc ce point est un point important euh
pour qu'on puisse supprimer euh des
département il faudrait d'abord que les
métropoles le réclament or sont-elles
toutes euh sur cette ligne-là ça c'est
un point d'interrogation qui est loin
d'être tranché pour le moment euh donc
ça c'est un c'est un point important le
deuxième point évidemment c'est que et
ça a été rappelé à l'instant les grandes
régions bah relégitim quand même assez
largement le le le département dans le
dans le dispositif
euh donc on a plutôt l'impression par
ailleurs et je crois que c'était aussi
un le sens de des propos de l'ensemble
des des candidats c'est que du côté des
associations d'élus du côté des élus de
base aussi euh il y a une demande de
respiration de stabilité du cadre
c'est-à-dire que tout le monde dit en ce
moment laissons-nous déjà 5 ans pour
digérer les réformes qui ont été
adoptées qui ont pas encore été
complètement mises en œuvre et dont on
ne connaît pas encore tous les effets
avant de jouer à nouveau le cas échéant
un jour à nouveau au jeu du mécano
territorial hein c'est ce que dit
François Fillon d'ailleurs Jean Réné le
SERT hein il dit et bien il faut laisser
les territoires s'organiser il appelle à
une nouvelle étape dans la
décentralisation mais pas de nouvelles
réformes territoriales en soi oui c'est
ce qu'ils disent beaucoup c'est-à-dire
ils ont relu montesquieux hein il faut
toucher aux loi que d'une main
tremblante euh et je pense que les les
les collectivités territoriales ont
besoin effectivement de de stabilité
pour pouvoir travailler dans la sérénité
ce qui ne veut pas dire que la loi NRE
soit une bonne loi moi je suis pas
favorable à cette loi mais j'estime
qu'il serait encore plus dommageable de
la remettre en cause sans arrêt et
toutes les modifications qui sont
proposées par les uns et par les autres
et notamment par les véritables
candidats à la présidence sont des
propositions effectivement qui son sont
fondées sur le volontariat si des
départements veulent fusionner ils
fusionnent si des départements et des
métropoles s'entendent pour que la
métropole devienne comme à Lyon euh
c'est l'exemple hein qui a été cité à
plusieurs reprises par Emmanuel Macron
mais je rejoins ce qui vient d'être dit
si vous voulez les métropoles il y en a
qui sont pas capables de prendre des
compétences départemental il y en a qui
en sont capables mais qui n'en veulent
pas moi j'ai j'ai dû négocier avec la
métropole de Lille j'ai eu beaucoup de
mal à faire en sorte qu'il me prennent 2
% du budget du département j'ai eu un
mel de chien et et mon département il a
toujours un budget qui est l'équivalent
du budget de la région de France ouais
c'est Trel oui c'est assz toujours assez
amusant parce que je trouve que benoî
amont a eu raison de de de démarrer son
discours sur ce sujet si le département
depuis une quinzaine d'années a souvent
était la la cible et le le commencement
de toute réforme territoriale à la fin
il est toujours en place c'est peut-être
que finalement comme c'est la
collectivité des solidarités comme c'est
la collectivité de l'action sociale
finalement c'est parce que peut-être que
ceux qui mettent en avant régulièrement
je pense une forme de technostructure à
la tête de notre notre pays qui propose
toujours les mêmes réformes à tous les
gouvernements qu'il soit de gauche ou
qu'il soit de droite bah finalement
c'est peut-être les despenses de
solidarité qui sont ciblés et d'ailleurs
c'est un c'est je partage le le point de
vue de Jean René le CF c'est que la
réalité c'est quand les métropoles
aimerait bien absorber le département
mais elles veulent jamais prendre en
charge les dépenses de solidarité
assumées par les département ces
dépenses de solidarité peut-être avec
vous Patrick Le lidc puisque ça était
aussi une des propositions avancées ce
matin est-ce qu'il faut recentraliser
justement et bien cette question de
versement de financement du RSA selon
vous alors moi je je je je mon rôle
n'est pas de vous faire une réponse
politique sur est-ce qu'il faut ou pas
euh par contre ce que je peux vous dire
c'est à l'instant qu'il y a quand même
une cohérence d'un certain point de vue
entre le propos d'Emmanuel Marcon qui
consiste à dire il faut renationaliser
les dépenses du RSA et euh on aurait la
possibilité plus facilement d'avoir des
métropoles candidates au fond à
l'absorption de l'échelon départemental
parce que il faut bien être conscient du
fait que ce qui fait peur aux métropole
ce sont évidemment les compétences
sociales du département qui coûte plus
cher que les ressources dont
qui pourrai leur être transféré euh et
donc de ce point de vue-là on sent
qu'effectivement il y a un package en
quelque sorte consistant à dire un je
renationalise parce qu'effectivement euh
il y a des inégalités très fortes que
cette mise à la charge des départements
du RSA et de l'ensemble des dépenses
sociales par les lois rafarin bah au
fond a déséquilibré quand même très
largement les budgets départementaux
mais de manière très très inégal selon
les départements sur ce plateau on a
deux représentants de département dont
les budgets sont tendus mais d'autres
sont dans des situations très
différentes et donc ont des budgets qui
restent relativement je dirais
confortabl et donc pour lesquels ce
sujet de la renationalisation du RSA
n'est pas un sujet et donc de ce point
de vue-là il y a bien un clivage au sein
même des départements avant de vous
demander votre avis jean- Rena lard je
vous propose justement un de réécouter
Emmanuel Macron et Benoît amont sur
cette question des dépenses de
solidarité je suis de ceux qui
soutiennent le principe de la
décentralisation des allocations
sociales qui avait été mise en œuvre par
Jean-Pierre rafarin au début des années
2000 parce qu'elle a eu des effets
positifs parce qu'elle a permis d'avoir
un service public plus proche la mise en
œuvre d'un suivi plus individualisé mais
il faut bien le dire sur certaines de
ces prestations les départements sont
devenus des pilleurs aveugle
dont les recettes n'ont absolument pas
la même dynamique ni la même logique de
dynamique que ces dépenses et donc en la
matière je pense en particulier à
plusieurs départements le département du
Nord qui connaît d'importantes
difficultés financières prèant tenail
entre la baisse des dotations de l'État
et l'augmentation du nombre de ménages
bénéficiant du RSA on demande
aujourd'hui au département de choisir
entre en quelque sorte les prestations
sociales l'école et la culture c'est ça
la situation dans laquelle on place
aujourd'hui les collectivités pour
mettre fin à cette dérive je souhaite
donc que le versement et le financement
du RSA soit
recentralisé il faudra prendre en charge
pour l'État la centralisation du
versement du futur revenu universel qui
englobe le RS revaloriser et donc
discuter avec vous des conditions dans
lesquelles aujourd'hui autour de 10
milliards d'euros je crois sont consenti
en dépenses par les départements pour
financer cela pour si grossièrement les
chiffres sont bons pour 60 % liés à ce
qui'est la compensation de l'État et 40
% à partir de ressources propres donc
c'est ces questionsl qu'il faudra
discuter voir de quelle manière nous
centralisons à nouveau ce qui doit
relever à mes yeux de la mise en
œuvre élémentaire de la solidarité
nationale par l'État Jean-René leerc
comment réagissez-vous à ces propos on
entendu Emmanuel Macron cité he votre
département justement et parl de payeurs
aveugles oui je je je crois qu'on on n
pas pu justement dialoguer c'est-à-dire
que moi je ne crois pas une seule
seconde que l'État va arriver pour dire
gentil département j'ai 10 milliards
effectivement je sais pas quoi en faire
donc je vais vous le donner et puis à la
limite moi je ne souhaite pas qu'il y
ait une une recentralisation totale du
financement du RSA lorsque manuel Vals
nous l'avait proposé après quand on a vu
ce dont il s'agissait il s'agissait de
nous piquer l'intégralité des restes à
charge de faire en sorte que les
départements pauvres comme la SA
SaintDenis ou le Nord il donnent leur sa
charge à tout jamais effectivement à
l'état et que les départements riches ne
donnent rien parce qu'effectivement ils
avaient pas de reste à charge ça c'est
absolument inqualifiable moi j'avais
fait des propositions avec un collègue
de gauche Michel dagber président du
conseil général du P decalis pour dire
demandons seulement à l'état de jouer
son rôle de péquateur entre les plus
favorisés et les moins favorisés ça
coûterait 1 milliard ça nous permettrait
de nous stabiliser et de faire notre
affaire du financement du RSA on
pourrait peut-être commencer par cela il
propose 10 milliards nous on en propose
un il devra accepter c'estan trousel moi
je remarque simplement que
Emmanuel Macron peut-être parce qu'il a
été un ancien ministre de l'économie et
des finances le le petit monde le petit
système médiatico-politique nous
explique qu'il est raisonnable sérieux
crédible et à l'inverse euh candidat que
je soutiens Benoît Hamont parce qu'il a
fait cette proposition de revenus
universel et est taxé de de farfelu je
remarque par exemple qui englobera le r
exactement je remarque par exemple que
ce matin donc Emmanuel Macron a Gén
généreusement euh donner 10 milliards au
département 10 milliards aux communes à
travers la taxe d'habitation personne ne
lui fait l'accusation d'être vraiment
irréalist de ne pas soucier des dépenses
publiques en revanche euh oui moi
j'assume de dire cette dépense elle
relève de la solidarité nationale parce
que la réalité c'est que ni Jean-René le
cerf ni moi nous fixons le montant et
les critères de de pour percevoir le RSA
donc ça relève de la solidarité
nationale je rappelle que si nous les
finançons c'est parce que un ancien
président de la République dans les
années 2000 en l'occurrence Jacques
Chirac avait promis une baisse massive
de l'impôt sur le revenu et qu'en
conséquence et bien c'est l'impôt local
qui de fait a été mise à contribution
pour financer cette dépense de
solidarité nationale donc à dépense de
solidarité nationale euh recette
nationale d'ailleurs je note là aussi
que ceux euh qui expliquent qu'il faut
euh réduire les dépenses publiques
continuer de baisser les les les
dotations font cette proposition tout de
même un peu contradictoire de mettre 10
milliards 10 milliards sur la table
doncir baation voulez Patrick lex c'est
vra que si les département perdent le
financement du RSA ils perdent aussi ils
vont être dépossédés de leurs
compétences et du coup à terme c'est
leur existence même qui sera menacé pas
forcément c'est-à-dire qu'on peut aussi
concevoir que dans une logique de
justice fiscal entre les contribuables
départementaux il y a une
nationalisation du financement et et en
même temps que cette compétence continue
d'être déléguée au département il y a un
dispositif qui fonctionne et donc il y a
pas forcément de raison de le mettre à
bas pour le le remplacer par quoi voilà
donc donc on peut concevoir le cas
échéant techniquement de faire
intervenir les CAF mais bon quel est le
bénéfice enfin voilà la question peut
mérite d'être d'être débattu je crois
pas que ce soit en tout cas pour le
moment directement la question qui est
posée euh la question qui est posée
c'est effectivement celle des inégalités
que génère en réalité la mise à la
charge des départements du financement
du RSA qui n'aurait jamais dû en réalité
à mon sens être transféré en tant que
charge ou alors il l'était à un moment
où on avait une fiscalité de
l'immobilier qui était extrêmement
dynamique parce queon on était en pleine
bulle immobilière et à partir moment où
les droits de mutation ont cessé
d'augmenter que par la suite bah
effectivement on s'est trouvé devant un
problème de financement qui un problème
désormais structurel Jean moi je crois
un peu comme vous que si on commence
effectivement à retirer l'intégralité du
financement du RSA au département parce
que c'est de la solidarité nationale
demain on va nous dire la pas c'est de
la solidarité nationale et après-demain
la PCH pration de compensation du
handicap c'est de la solidarité
nationale en outre je pense qu'on est
beaucoup plus compétent que l'État pour
gérer le problème du RSA que ce soit
l'insertion sociale ou que ce soit
l'insertion économique quand il y a une
volonté politique moi je l'ai bien vu
dans le Nord dans le Nord on a fait
baisser et pourtant jeen le vous avez
plusieurs fois tiré la sonette d'alarm
justement sur le manque de moyens
justement bien sûr mais je demande des
moyens à l'état mais je lui demande pas
de reprendre globalement la compétence
la compétence on est mieux placé que
l'État pour la gérer je demande que les
moyens ce soit simplement le moyen
évident d'un état c'est-à-dire de faire
la péréquation entre les riches et les
pauvres ça le précédent gouvernement ne
l'a jamais fait visiblement c'est
là-dessus qu'il a été largement critiqué
par l'ensemble des candidats c'est pas
TR moi encore une fois je je je pense
qu'à cette dépense de solidarité
nationale doit relever une une recette
de de national en revanche oui parce que
nous connaissons notre territoire nous
connaissons les acteurs locaux nous
connaissons les les dispositif de
formation de qualification les
possibilités d'insertion professionnelle
sur le marché du travail local bien
évidemment que même si le RSA ou le
revenu universel dans le cadre de la
proposition de Benoît amont je souhaite
et c'est la proposition aussi de que
fait Benoît amont c'est que les les
départements continuer de continue
pardon de mener les politiques
d'accompagnement d'un verion
professionnelle des des des des
allocataires du RSA mais la motivation
de la remise à l'emploi la motivation de
la remise à l'emploi elle est d'autant
plus forte dans les départements qu'ils
savent très bien que s'ils ne
parviennent pas à réussir cette mise à
l'emploi ils sont juridiquement morts
alors Patrick lidek est-ce que les temps
s'annonce difficile pour les
départements pour les collectivités
territoriales on a entendu finalement
François Fillon annoncer qu'il allait
continuer à la baisse des dotations aux
collectivités de 7,5 milliards
d'euros sur 5 ans oui ce n'est ce n'est
pas le seul est-ce que les départements
vont devoir aussi se serer la ceinture
sans vraiment avoir de proposition ce
qui concerne on le voit le financement
du RSA par exemple moi je pense si vous
voulez que queles que soient les
promesses des candidats la contrainte
budgétaire elle va s'appliquer queles
que soi les promesses des candidats et
donc certains affichent des chiffres de
baisse de la DGF la baisse de la DGF si
la croissance n'est pas au rendez-vous
et doation globale de
fonctionnementilà donc donc concrètement
si l'État n'a pas de recette fiscale en
croissance euh qu'il est son budget est
toujours en déficit bien au-delà des
engagements qui ont été pris sur le plan
européen si par ailleurs les taux
d'intérêt remonte comme ça ça semblait
devoir être le cas et bien la charge de
la dette va s'allordir et donc forcément
euh euh ça n'annonce pas je dirais une
une une période particulièrement
heureuse pour les collectivités
territoriales qui seront mises à
contribution au même titre d'ailleurs
que la sécurité sociale et au même titre
que l'État le budget de l'État lui-même
même hein donc je pense que ce sont des
éléments qui sont malheureusement à ce
stade relativement inévitables sauf à
réussir à trouver un élixir de jouvance
et à générer une croissance qui ne
semble pas pour le moment en tout cas au
rendez-vous donc la santé des
collectivité elle est indexée sur la
croissance globale Stéphan trousel et
bon c'est aussi un débat de politique
économique en général parce que moi je
fais partie de ceux et c'est le cas
deont qui considère qu'il va falloir
desserrer les taux euré je ve dire on se
on se met dans cette règle absolue des 3
% oui bah cet objectif de 3 % il a été
fixé de manière totalement arbitraire si
ça aurait pu TR ça aurait pu êtreaura
expationch je rappelle qu'il y a aussi
dans les traités européens c'est la
croissance anticipée était de 3% moi je
fais partie de ceux par exemple qui
considèrent qu'il y a un certain nombre
de dépenses publiques qui ne devrait pas
être comptabilisé NOTAM notamment en ce
qui concerne la France compte tenu de de
son engagement en matière de politique
de défense ce que n'assum pas un certain
nomut d' et donc il y a cet enjeu oui
mais c'est il existe par ailleurs je
rappelle que y compris pour un
gouvernement que dirigé par ma famille
politique l'État était capable de
trouver 40 milliards pour financer le
cice et le Pacte des responsabilités
dont on ne peut pas dire que ni sur le
chômage ni sur la qu'il faut siev la
question des des collectivités une loi
de finances dédié aux collectivités oui
ou il nous faut de la stabilité de la
visibilité et par ailleurs et je crois
que là aussi il y avait une forme de
consensus ce matin il faut en finir avec
cette inflation normative et
réglementaire qui pèse sur les
collectivités et et y compris que
constitue pour nous des dépenses très
importantes et et puis il faut arrêter
la discrimination si vous voulez sinon
on va saisir le Défenseur des droits
puisque le département et la
collectivité la plus discriminée les
communes par exemple elles ont
effectivement la baisse des dotations et
la la BA des dotation on l'a freiné les
régions elles n'ont pas les mêmes le
même impact sur la solidarité nationale
on leur a donné la possibilité d'avoir
effectivement les moyens d'avoir des
revenus plus importants en terme de TVA
nous nous avons à la fois la baisse
maximale des dotations et nous avons
l'envolé des allocations individuelles
de solidarité ce n'est pas tenable on
reçoit actuellement des courriers de
collègues présidents de conseil
départementaux qui sont considérés comme
plus favorisés que les nôtres où les
présidents disent il y a 5 mois de RSA
qu'on ne va pas pouvoir budgetter
qu'est-ce qu' va payer ce sera les les
les allocataires n'auront plus leur
argent ou alors c'est l'État qui donnera
de l'argent à la CAF ce qui montre bien
que le système il est réellement au bout
de sa logique et que la situation des
départements n'est comparable à la
situation d'aucune autre colletivité
alors même que quand on regarde par
exemple les effectifs de la fonction
publique moi je veux bien qu'on regarde
l'évolution des effectifs de la fonction
publique dans les départements et dans
les autres au niveau de collectivité et
on
verra merci Stéphane trousel vous
soutenez Benoît amont Jean leer où
est-ce que votre choix est fait pour
cette élection écoutez moi je regarde
avec beaucoup d'attention la famille
politique qui était la mienne devrait
m'amener naturellement à soutenir
François Fillon ce sera peut-être ce que
je ferais vraisemblablement même mais je
trouve que le discours d'Emmanuel Macron
est un discours tout à fait
intéressant on s'arrête un instant sur
un des enjeux de la campagne
présidentielle aujourd'hui comment
lutter contre la désertification
médicale notre équipe s'est rendue à
belle île en mer dans le morbillan il il
y a 3 ans cette île ne comptait plus que
trois médecins généralistes dont un qui
souhaitait prendre sa retraite alors il
a fallu mettre en place une nouvelle
organisation du travail pour faire venir
des médecins une solution originale a
été trouvée et vous allez le voir ça
marche reportage de Samia de chir avec
Audrey
buetaz nous sommes à belleîle en mer une
petite île de 5000 habitants malgré la
beauté de ces paysages ce petit bout de
terre a longtemps eu du mal à attirer
des jeunes médecins jusqu'à ce qu'un
généraliste a l'idée d'une solution
originale un statut mixte où les
médecins partagent leur temps entre
l'hôpital et leur cabinet pour
comprendre comment ça fonctionne on part
tout de suite à l'hôpital de
[Musique]
bellille docteur Pinard bonjour bonjour
alors vous êtes médecin généraliste et
pourtant vous travaillez dans un hôpital
c'est assez inhabituel oui c'est un
concept un petit peu novateur quand je
suis arrivé sur l'île en fait je
souhaitais m'y installer et j'ai j'y ai
découvert l'hôpital de
proximité il était vide seul généraliste
de l'établissement Stéphane Pinard
décide de réinventer son métier il
installe son cabinet dans l'hôpital pour
les consultations du quotidien en tant
que médecin libéral mais il réserve une
partie de son temps aux urgences en tant
que salarié de l'hôpital donc voilà la
salle de de déchoquage on reçoit les
gens en urgence
Z elle est équipée pour prendre en
charge les urgences vitales infarctus
AVC comment vous avez eu l'idée de
mettre ce système en place est-ce que
c'est né de vos expériences passé en
tant que généraliste sur d'autres
territoires j'étaé installé tout de
suite dans un milieu rural pendant 7 ans
ça a été 7ette année de de non médecine
c'est être installé aujourd'hui c'est
beaucoup de renouvellement d'ordonnance
on va vite c'est 40 consultations par
jour les urgences vitales on peut pas
les voir parce qu'on a plus le temps
donc quand on nous appelle pour une
suture une fracture une suspici d'AVC
faites le 15 faites le 15 et moi j'ai
envie de dire que j'avais j'avais
l'impression d'avoir remplacé mon
stetthoscope par un stylo docteur je
crois qu'il y a des patients qui vous
attend dans salle d'attente donc on va
pas vous mettre plus en retard et puis
on va vous suivre un petit peu dans vos
consultations ou on y
va vous avez rendez-vous ou pas
rendez-vous oui rendez-vous j'ai pas de
rendez-vous et ben on y va alors
qu'est-ce qui vous amène ben farait me
me passer mon mon ordonnance je vais
vous donner ça quand même à belle île
plus qu'ailleurs la présence des
généralistes est cruciale on est vers
les 16 sans eux il faudrait aller
consulter sur le continent c'est très
important parce que s'il y a sil y a que
juste un généraliste puis qu'on est
obligé d'aller voir un spécialiste est
obligé d'aller l'autre côté bon ben
maintenant il viien des spécialistes
c'est vrai que làdessus on est quand
même gâté parce que de certaines î il y
a rien
rien depuis son arrivée en 2013 Stéphane
Pinard a été rejoint par se autres
médecins séduit par ce mélange entre la
médecine de ville et l'hôpital ha de
poids bonjour bonjour Vous vous
coordonnez le service des
hospitalisation à domicile alors en fait
c'est pour s'occuper des patients qui
souhaitent rester chez eux mais qui ont
besoin des moyens de l'hôpital donc
principalement les patients en fin de
vie et ben on vous suit ha de poid s'est
installé à bellî il y a 3 ans avec son
conjoint et ses quatre enfants ha vous
êtes originaire de région parisienne et
vous avez choisi de venir vous installer
à bellîle pour votre première
installation puisque vous n'avez que 33
ans qu'est-ce qui vous a séduit dans ce
projet malgré l'insularité on se sent
pas du tout seul et et on a l'impression
de faire une une médecine peut-être plus
complète est-ce que vous auriez pu vous
vous installer seul en cabinet dans un
territoire rural j'aurais pas été
capable de m'installer
seule isolé loin d'un centre hospitalier
malgré tout et puis avec un rythme de
vie qui était sûrement pas compatible
avec avec mes quatre enfants en
travaillant en équipe les médecins de lî
ont plus de temps pour leur vie
personnelle bonjour un système qui a
fait de lîle l'un des territoires les
plus attractifs de
Bretagne et je vous propose d'ailleurs
d'écouter Frédéric Lear c'est le
président de la communauté de communes
de bellî enmer il a répondu aux
questions de Samia dechir Frédéric
Legars vous êtes président de la
communauté de commune de bellî en mer il
y a 4 ans il n'y avait plus que trois
médecins sur ce territoire dont un qui
allait partir à la retraite est-ce que
Bell a failli devenir un désert médical
euh on peut considérer la chose de cette
manière effectivement avec trois
médecins pour 5500 habitants à l'année
et avec des pointes estivales à 40000
habitants on pouvait considérer que
bellî allait être dans une situation
assez critique et et être qualifié comme
étant un désert médical et quelle
conséquence ça aurait eu pour un
territoire comme bellîle cette
désertification médicale alors en
premier lieu une une vraie perte de
confiance des citoyens vis vie de leur
capacité à se faire soigner sur belleîle
et puis de vrais problèmes sanitaires
avec des impossibilités d'apporter aux
citoyens l'offre de soins nécessaire à
la à leur à leurs besoins véritable
est-ce qu'il n aurait pas eu aussi des
conséquences en terme d'emploi une fois
qu'il y ait une désertification médicale
est-ce que ça peut avoir des
conséquences sur d'autres pans de de la
vie de l'île euh bah bien sûr puisque on
sait très bien que pour venir
s'installer sur une île il faut avant
tout être en capacité d'offrir des
services publics et l'offre médicale est
le principal service attendu par une
population qui souhaite rester sur un
territoire alors il y a des communes où
les maires propose des grosses sommes
d'argent pour attirer les jeunes
médecins et où malgré tout personne ne
vient alors que vous ici vous avez
triplé le nombre de médecins en
seulement 4 ans est-ce que la clé du
succès à balî c'est pas que la solution
est venue des médecins eux-mêmes alors
oui la solution est venue en partie des
médecins eux-mêmes mais ça a surtout été
une solution qui s'est mise en place
grâce à la mobilisation
euh d'un grand nombre d'acteurs on a mis
en place ce qu'on a appelé un contrat
local de santé euh donc ça a été un
souhait de l'agence régional de santé du
département du morbillan et puis surtout
des élus de Belle Île en- mer qui ont
réussi à mobiliser euh tous les
professionnels de santé autour d'un
projet médical partagé euh la population
a également été impliquée dans cette
dans cette opération de mobilisation et
donc on a pu grâce au savoir de de
chacun et à la au fait que que certaines
personnes se soient impliquées vraiment
de manière très conséquente dans cette
élaboration de contrat local de santé et
de projets de territoire médical on a pu
euh et bien être de de de devenir un
devenir un territoire attractif alors
qu' au préalable on était un territoire
en en désertification médicale et vous
êtes aujourd'hui l'un des territoires
les plus attractifs de Bretagne comment
ça se passe sur les autres îles du
Ponant qui entourent bel île est-ce
qu'il y a assez de médecins alors sur
les autres îles bretonne euh il y a
parfois pas de médecin du tout c'est
même le contraire qui se passe hein le
les médecins ne ont très peu de
possibilité d'exercer sur sur les autres
îles donc on a réussi à grâce à
l'expérimentation de bî en mer à
dupliquer le contrat local de santé de
Belly en mer pour le le l'étendre à
l'intégralité des des îles du Ponant et
ça va permettre et bien de de développer
à sur chacune des îles à leur tour un
vrai contrat local pour faire en sorte
que c'est ces îles deviennent aussi
attractives Frédéric legar je rappelle
que vous êtes président de la communauté
de communes de B enmer merci beaucoup
d'avoir répondu à nos
questions quel sera le candidat qui
baissera le plus les impôts la question
risque de peser au moment de mettre son
bulletin dans l'urne alors que les
Français jugent très sévèrement le
système fiscal actuel quelles sont les
propositions des candidats on voit tout
ça avec Éloïse
Grégoire les Fran porte un regard plutôt
négatif sur leur fiscalité selon un
sondage hiob Fiducial le système fiscal
est un système injuste à 93 % compliqué
à 88 et qui n'a pas su se moderniser à
63 %. concernant l'augmentation des
impôts Nicolas Sarkozi et François
Hollande sont chacun désigné comme
responsable pour 49 %. un constat plutôt
sévère sur les deux derniers quinquenas
à quelques jours de l'élection
présidentielle Emmanuel Macron est
considéré comme le plus apte à améliorer
la situation fiscale pour 30 % Marine Le
Pen elle est à 19 % et François Fillon
est en 3e position avec 17 % 71 % des
personnes questionnées ne sont pas
favorables à la suppression de l'impôt
sur la fortune même si le candidat dans
marche souhaite lui le réformer en
exonérant l'ensemble des valeurs
mobilières la hausse du taux de TVA de
20 à 22 % est l'une des mesures proposé
par le candidat de la droite François
Fillon mais 92 % des sondés la rejettent
parmi les différentes propositions des
candidats de mesures sont largement
plébiscitées la baisse de la TVA sur les
produits de première nécessité à 89 % et
la diminution de l'impôt sur le revenu à
80 %. le candidat François Hollande
voulait fusionner cet impôt avec la CSG
un chantier abandonné au cours de son
mandat sur une échelle de 1 à 10 les
sondés estiment que la fiscalité est
importante à 6,4 dans leur intention de
vote 51 % d'entre eux pensent qu'au
lendemain de l'élection présidentielle
les impôts vont augmenter un ralbol
fiscal qui devrait jouer un rôle
déterminant dans le vote des
Français et on ouvre le premier débat de
présidentiel 360 avec mes invités sur ce
plateau Vincent de lae bonsoir sénateur
udi de lessonne vous êtes membres de
l'équipe de campagne de François fillan
justement sur ces questions fiscales on
va bien sûr en parler sur ce plateau
Philippe Martin bonsoir bons professeur
d'économie à Scien po conseil économie
économique d'Emmanuel Macron merci
d'être avec nous j'accueille également
Jean Messia bonsoir vous êtes le
coordinateur du projet présidentiel de
Marine Le Pen et pour nous éclairer
également Mathieu plan bonsoir
économiste à l'OFCE on vient de
l'entendre la fiscalité c'est un sujet
sensible mais d'un côté les Français
expliquent aussi à travers notre sondage
sur ralbol fiscal il trouent que le
système est injuste compliqué les
recettes souvent mal utilisées pour
autant est-ce qu'il faut tout remettre à
PLA peut-être première question avec
vous Philippe Martin pense que ils ont
raison de penser que le le système est
injuste et compliqué il est injuste
parce que on l'a vu et on prend nous
l'exemple en particulier de la taxe
d'habitation c'est c'est une taxe
extrêmement injuste alors on rappelle
qu'Emmanuel Macron justement veut la
supprimé pour 80 % franç des Français
parce que c'est une taxe qui taxe plus
en fait ceux qui sont les ménages les
plus modeste et 600 € en part en moyenne
pour pour un Français donc de ce point
de vue c'est c'est une réduction
d'impôts qui nous paraît juste et par
ailleurs on veut aussi faire des
réductions d'impôts sur les entreprises
c'est c'est équilibré hein puisqueil y a
10 milliard en gros sur les ménages et
10 milliards sur les entreprises et là
c'est la diminution de l'impôt sur les
sociétés de 33 % à 25 % ce qui nous
ramène euh vers la moyenne vers la
moyenne de la zone euro ouais sans tout
remettre à plat comme système pas de
révolution fiscale c'est ce qu'on dit
non et il s'est engagé aussi à ce que on
change si on change un impôt on le
change qu'une seule fois parce qu' en
effet il y a beaucoup trop euh
d'instabilité fiscale en France et c'est
ce qui fait aussi que les Français n'y
comprennent plus rien et trouvent ça
extrêmement compliqué ouais Jean Messia
sera le bol fiscal est-ce qu'il est
entendu aussi dans et bien dans le
programme de Marine Le Pen est-ce
qu'elle tient compte de cet aspect on
sait qu'elle veut justement élargir hein
l'impôt sur le revenu à tous Aujourd'hui
on rappelle qu'il est payé par un
Français sur de à peu près non non il y
a on envisage simplement de réduire le
effectivement les les trois premières
tranches de l'impôt sur le revenu de de
10 % mais globalement si vous voulez le
ce sondage montre avant tout le regard
que porte les Français sur la politique
tout court avant que ça soit la
politique fiscale parce que la politique
fiscale n'est qu'un des aspects de la
politique économique euh donc en fait
les Français commentent là le bilan des
30 des 20 ou 30 dernières années de de
de gouvernement dans le cours de au
cours desquels si vous voulez la
politique fiscale est restée la dernière
politique à peu près souveraine euh
puisque comme vous le savez la politique
budgétaire n'est plus de notre ressort
ou quasiment plus la politique monétaire
non plus et donc on arrive à une
politique fiscale si vous voulez qui
matraque en permanence les mêmes
personnes à assiette constante la France
n'étant plus capable justement d'élargir
l'activité de créer une dynamique
économique seul seul à notre sens
susceptible de faire baisser
véritablement et sur le long terme la
pression fiscale ouais Vincent DEA et ce
matraquage fiscal c'est un argument
aussi que vous entendez sera le bol
fiscal des Français B ça fait des années
qu'on le dénonce c'est vrai que il y a
des gouvernements successifs qui ont
augmenté les impôts le dernier n'a pas
été le moindre puisque le kquena de
Hollande avec comme conseiller Emmanuel
Macron qui a été aussi ministre de
l'Économie pendant 2 ans a augmenté
assez largement les impôts et le poids
des prélèvements obligatoires s alourdi
alors bien sûr sur la fin de la période
il s'est plutôt stabilisé mais il s'est
largement alourdi alors moi je voudrais
simplement dire par rapport au sondage
il y a quand même de c'est c'est facile
d'interroger les gens en disant si on
baisse est-ce que vous êtes plutôt
favorable si on augmente est-ce que vous
êtes plutôt favorable les résultats sont
clairs c'est assez facile si on explique
pas pourquoi moi je pense que la
fiscalité c'est un outil c'est un outil
qui est aujourd'hui beaucoup trop
compliqué en France c'est vrai il est
trop lourd et trop compliqué donc il
faut le baisser et aussi le simplifier
et pas le faire tout le temps non plus
mais le faire une bonne fois au début
d'un quinquena et de de façon à ce que
les effets soient durables mais par
exemple l'augmentation de la TVA moi
j'aimerais bien qu'on y revienne parce
que elle a un but l'augmentation de la
TVA c'est de réduire les charges social
c'est de réduire les charges sociales et
notamment sur les salaires ça veut dire
que les salaires des personnes vont
augmenter et ça il faut qu'ils le
sacheent parce que la hausse de la TVA
c'est pour transférer une partie des
charges sociales sur la TVA et notamment
aussi sur les importations c'est ça qui
est important parce qu' aujourd'hui les
importations elles ne payent pas ne paye
pas la couverture sociale en France et
on a une couverture sociale qui est très
généreuse tant mieux mais il faut
pouvoir continuer à la à la payer et
pour la payer il faut pouvoir faire
payer les importations ouais Mathieu
plan quel regard portez-vous justement
sur ce qu'on vient de dire à la fois cet
aspect et bien un système complexe
injuste avec une mauvaise compréhension
des recettes qui sont utilisées alors je
pense qu'il y a d'abord plusieurs choses
c'est c'est il y a beaucoup de confusion
parce que il y a énormément de mesures
fiscales ces dernières années faut juste
rappeler hein ce qui s'est produit
depuis 2010 on avait un déficit
extrêmement élevé suite à la crise la
volonté de réduire rapidement ses
déficits et le choix de le faire
principalement par la fiscalité donc le
choc fiscal a commencé en 2011 on voit
qu'on a une force augmentation des
prélèvements ça a été poursuivi
effectivement sous le kquenat de
François Hollande et puis après en 2014
il y a le tournant vers la politique de
l'offre et donc les allègements de
cotisation le pack de responsabilité le
cice il a fallu le financer donc vous
retrouver dans une situation où au final
la fiscalité à partir de 2014 sur les
entreprises diminue c'est un soutien au
tissu productif c'est un peu ce que vous
souhaitez faire en revanche il a
financer à la fois la réduction des
déficits et cette compétitivité or au
final vous arrivez en 2017 avec des
niveaux de prélèvement sur les ménages
historiquement élevés et les entreprises
qui ont retrouvé un peu d'oxygène par
les baisses de prélèvement mais le
ralbol fiscal en fait on a tendance à le
concentrer sur l'impôt sur le revenu
sauf qu'il y a beaucoup d'autres
prélèvements et sur les ménages faut
rappeler que l'impôt sur revenu c'est
que 15 % de l'impôt sur ménage parce que
à côté de ça vous allez la fiscalité
indirecte vous avez la fiscalité
écologique vous avez la fiscalité locale
vous avez les cotisation sociale vous
allevez la CSG et donc c'est l'ensemble
de ce périmètrre là qui est important et
surtout ce qu'on maîtrise assez mal
c'est quels ont été les impacts
redistributifs là-dedans c'està-dire que
est-ce que ça a été fait de façon
égalitaire est-ce que ça a été fait avec
une ambition de réforme fiscale
d'ensemble non absolument pas on a
superposé des couches et donc plus
personne n'y comprend rien et donc les
gens ont l'impression qui en fait qu'
payent beaucoup d'impôts et en même
temps on a des services publics qui ont
plutôt diminué parce qu'on a la
réduction des penses public donc il y a
effectivement il y a un travail de
pédagogie à faire de mise à plat aussi
bien du côté des entreprises aussi bien
du côté des ménages le risque c'est
encore de rebousculer le système et
effectivement d'arriver dans une
situation où plus personne ne comprendra
rien jusqu'à un ralbol fiscal total quoi
avec une mesure qui est le prélèvement à
la source qui va être mise en place ça
est-ce que si Emmanuel Macron et bien
arrive au pouvoir est-ce qu'il revient
sur cette mesure Philippe Martin non a
priori il il garde ce prélèvement à la
source ouais nous nous comptons au
contraire la la remettre en cause
puisquen fait le prélèvement à la source
si vous voulez ne fait que transférer la
charge du calcul de l'impôt de
l'administration fiscale vers les
entreprises avec en plus un problème de
transfert de données de personnel si
vous voulez par rapport à la situation
de votre ménage de vos enfants et cetera
euh al à l'employeur donc nous sommes
effectivement extrêmement contre cette
mesure que nous entendons abroger si
nous arrivons aux responsabilités ouais
V de oui Franois Fillon a annoncé que il
ne souhaitait pas maintenir en l'état
pour l'instant la réforme il faut savoir
que le prélèvement à la source sur le
fond ça devrait être une bonne mesure ça
devrait être une bonne mesure si l'impôt
était pas si compliqué l'impôt français
est très compliqué donc si l'impôt était
simple c'est vrai que ça serait ça
serait une bonne mesure et ça serait une
simplification pour tout le monde mais
là présenté comme une réforme de ça va
pas simplifier ça ça va pas simplifier
du tout pour le contribuable
contribuable il a il a des avantages des
des retenus des des choses qui va devoir
de toute façon faire connaître à
l'administration fiscale pour corriger
ces prélèvements les prélèvements qui
ont été fait donc en fait pour lui c'est
pas une simplification pour les
entreprises c'est une complexification
donc aujourd'hui on voit pas les
avantages on devrait les voir mais pour
les voir il faut d'abord commencer par
simplifier l'impôt pour P voir ensuite
effectivement prélevé à la source sans
compter que la notion de ménage
disparaît dans cette approche
c'est-à-dire qu'on n'impose plus un
ménage comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui on
impose un individu
en non je pense qu mê il a un point
important moi je pense que c'est plutôt
une bonne mesure c'estd que au moins bon
effectivement il y a pas de modification
du système fiscal on garde le ccient
conjugal le ccient familial il y aura
une déclaration d'impôt la chose
intéressante c'est que d'avoir moins de
décalage entre l'impôt payé et les
revenus le problème c'est que quand vous
avez des revenus fluctuants vous pouvez
vous retrouver avoir justement des
prélèvements qui correspondent pas à
votre situation budgétaire ou fiscale du
moment et donc vous avez des décalages
importants soit parce que vous perdez
votre travail soit parce que vous êtes
chef d'entreprise et vous avez des
revenus fluctuants et donc ça c'est un
vrai problème donc le prélèvement à la
source permet d' moins de coller mieux à
la situation économique ou fiscale du
ménage à un moment donné donc je trouve
que ça c'est plutôt une bonne mesure et
du coup je je pense qu'il faut la
maintenir ou je voudrais qu'on s'arrête
également sur une des propositions de
Benoît Hamont qui veut reprendre ce
qu'avait finalement voulu faire
Jean-Marc h à savoir la fusion et bien
de la CSG avec l'impôt sur le revenu ça
c'est un appel à une véritable
révolution fiscale c'est le seul
candidat Benoît amont à reprendre cette
mesure qu'en pensez-vous Mathieu plan
alors il faut préciser les contours de
la mesure d'abord est-ce qu'on le fait à
on va dire à budget constant ou est-ce
que justement l'idée c'est de redonner
un peu du souffle aux classe moyenne
parce que il y a quand même cette idée
derrière là c'est qu'aujourd'hui
effectivement l'impôt sur le revenu est
quand même très concentré en tout cas il
y a moins de 50 % des ménages qui le
payent donc alors que le CSG vous le
payez à partir du premier OS c'est une
c'est ce qu'on appelle une flag taxe
c'est-àdire que le taux est constant dès
le premier donc l'idée effectivement
dans la fusion c'est de dire c'est une
façon de rebarimiser tout ça et si vous
voulez redonner du poir d'achat à
travers la fiscalité effectivement c'est
des solution après il y a quand même un
certain nombre de problème c'estd qu'on
voit que l'impôt sur revenu est
familialisé la CSG est individualisée
c'est en fonction de votre salaire pas
de votre situation familiale et donc il
y a aussi toutes ces aspects là qu'il
faudra traiter il y a le fait que l'impô
sur revenu a beaucoup de niches fiscales
la CAG pas du tout et donc la fusion
nécessite au-delà même de l'idée de
redistribuer des richesses plutôt sur
les classes moyennes ou du PO d'achat de
savoir est-ce qu'on va plutôt vers
l'individualisation ou plutôt la CSG va
plutôt se caler sur l'Impôt sur revenu
et ça c'est pas clair pour le moment
ouais Philippe Martin Emmanuel Macron
n'en veut pas de cette fusion non parce
que un des dangers c'est que c'est que
toutes les les niches fiscales qu'on a
sur l'Impôt sur revenu ne gangraine en
fait la base fiscale de de de la CSG euh
je dis pas que c'est c'est parfait comme
comme système mais je pense que on il
faut pas ajouter les complexités au
complexités al en revanche moi je suis
aussi favorable aller vers plus
d'individualisation de l'impôt on le
sait en particulier pour le travail des
femmes euh c'est un point important
parce que aujourd'hui en fait euh dans
un couple s'il y a une grosse différence
de salaire entre l'homme et la femme euh
ça incite peu euh la femme à à
travailler plus puisqu'elle est taxée à
un niveau très important donc je pense
que ça c'est un point important et c'est
pour ça que on donne l'option
l'individualisation euh sur l'impô sur
la revenu ouais Jean Messia pas de
hausse de la CG dans le programme de
Marine Le Pen euh par contre ce que je
voudrais V vraiment revenir là-dessus
c'est que aujourd'hui si vous voulez la
politique fiscale c'est vraiment une
gestion de la besina si vous voulez
c'est-à-dire qu'on a eu une période très
austéritaire qui contraint l'activité et
donc la politique fiscale se complexifie
d'une certaine façon parce que on est en
permanence à la recherche de solution
pour contrebalancer une baisse
tendantielle des recettes donc nous
notre projet il est cohérent c'estàd
d'un côté on veut recréer de l'activité
notamment avec la réindustrialisation
avec le retour de la souveraineté qui va
nous donner des outils pour agir et de
l'autre côté effectivement la
orientation de la politique fiscale vers
un allègement de la pression fiscale à
la fois sur les ménages modestes sur les
petites et moyennes entreprises qui sont
qui font partie de notre priorité
puisque les grands groupes par
définition nont pas n'ont pas besoin et
en plus il procèdent à des optimisations
fiscales et à des évasions fiscales donc
nous notre projet est cohérent parce
qu'il faut agir sur les deux branches
c'estd d'un côté l'activité et de
l'autre côté la politique fiscale ouais
Vincent delay sur cette question fusion
C on propose pas du tout la fusion de la
la CSG de l'impôt sur revenu on voudrait
simplifier déjà l'impôt sur le revenu
avant toute chose et euh on souhaite
alléger la fiscalité à la fois des
ménages mais aussi beaucoup des
entreprises de façon à redonner des
capitaux aussi à l'économie parce que
une voiture elle avance pas sans
carburant et une économie elle avance
pas sans capitaux et aujourd'hui on a
besoin de redonner ces marges de
manœuvre aux entreprises pour créer des
emplois et c'est ça la logique fiscale
qui est celle de François Fillon et il
faut pas oublier aussi que pour baisser
les impôts moi je l'ai dit toujours au
Sénat il faut d'abord commencer par
baisser la dépense publique et ça il y a
pas beaucoup de candidats qui s'engagent
dans cette voie làà et pour baisser la
dépense publique il faut réformer si on
ne réforme pas sur le fond on narrivera
jamais à baisser les impôts donc il faut
que les Français comprennent bien que il
veulent des baisses d'impôts et je
comprends bien moi moi je suis le
premier à les vouloir mais pour cela il
faut qu'on arrête la croissance de la
dépense publique qui n'a qui a été
ininterrompu depuis des années et des
années donc il faut vraiment rentrer
dans un système où fait baisser comme
dans les collectivités dans les
collectivités on a baissé nos nos
budgets on les a pas moins augmenté
qu'avant on les a baissé donc simplement
on a plus de collectivité ce qui fait
que globalement le budget des
collectivités parce Queen France on
multiplie les structures donc il faut
arrêter cette multiplication des
structures faut simplifier et il faut
baisser la dépense publique pour pouvoir
baisser les impôts et ça c'est la
logique de François Fillon franis qui
veut aussi supprimer l'ISF Vincent de la
il est un peu le alors l'ISF c'est c'est
par rapport au capitaux hein je disais
tout à l'heure l'économie a besoin de
capitaux aujourd'hui on a découragé
beaucoup de détenteurs de capitaux et
notre ISF alors moi j'ai quelques
nuances sur ce sujetl je suis à l'UDI et
j'ai pas forcément par participer dès le
départ à la définition du projet c'est
vrai que sur l'ISF moi je serais plutôt
pour un un fort allègement plutôt qu'une
suppression mais il faut redonner au
détenteurs de capitaux l'envie
d'investir dans dans notre pays ouis la
suppression de l'ISF on sait que c'est
c'est particulièrement sensible Mathieu
plan moi à mon sens le le le le problème
que ça pose c'est c'est d'un côté
augmenter la TVA et supprimer les SF
c'estd que effectivement la TVA tout le
monde la paye et de mesure du programme
de F plus vous êtes en bas de l'échelle
des revenus plus la part de TVA payer
est importante à l'inverse l'ISF est
concentré sur sur les produits de
première nécessité non mais sur et donc
il y a quand même un transfert c'est
qu'au final globalement c'est plutôt les
classes moyennes et classes populaires
qui vont financer ce programme par la
hausse de la TVA la réduction de la
dépense publique on sait que c'est
quelque chose qui est antirredistributif
la dépense publique participe à 80 % la
réduction des inégalités par l'éducation
la santé un certain nombre de choses
donc si vous réduisez la dépense
publique vous baissez la fiscalité sur
entreprise et la fiscalité sur le
capital et vous augmentez vous réduisez
P pens publi et vous augmentez la TVA
vous allez avoir quelque chose qui est
trèsribuê très inégalitair qui restque
d'être très inégalitaire donc c'est pour
ça et et d'ailleurs on le voit ça a été
aussi sûrement une des erreurs du
peut-être du K passé c'est qu'il y a eu
beaucoup fait sur la dépense publique
beaucoup pour baisser la fiscalité
entreprises mais assez peu finalement
pour soutenir le point d'achat d'un
certain nombre de catégories sociales et
notamment on s'est retrouvé avec une
politique d'offre qui a été pas si
efficace ouou moins efficace que ce
qu'on aurait pu espérer parce que
justement on a tapé trop sur la demand
et notamment on a tassé quand même
beaucoup le pouvoir d'achat des classes
moyennes Philippe Martin Emmanuel Macron
veut transformer l'ISF en un impôt sur
la fortune immobilière qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire comment ça va fonctionner ben
c'est très simple on garde l'ISF mais on
en enlève tout ce qui est pas immobilier
donc donc l'objectif c'est assez clair
he c'est de dire que tout le capital
productif on veut pas le taxer on veut
pas le mettre sur sur sur l'impôt sur la
fortune donc l'objectif c'est que en
effet il faut qu'il y ait plus de
capital en France mais que ce soit du
capital productif
et de ce point de vue en effet ça
signifie queon concentre l'ISF sur
l'immobilier qui est plus une rente que
du du du capital productif alors par
ailleurs moi je suis d'accord que en
effet si on veut baisser les impôts il
faut baisser les dépenses mais il faut
le faire de manière à la fois juste et
assez équilibré sur le plan
macroéconomique c'est-à-dire que moi je
considère que une baisse de 100
milliards des dépenses publiques he
puisque c'est l'objectif de de François
Fillon c'est gigantesque et là en effet
il y a vraiment un un un CVE dans er de
casser la croissance donc de fait il
faut baisser les dépenses parce que
sinon vous baisserez pas les impôts ça
c'est clair et puis il faut baisser les
les déficits il faut le faire de manière
équilibrée et donc nous on est sur un
étiage de 50 milliards 50 milliards en
fin de kakena ce qui nous paraît
beaucoup plus juste et beaucoup plus
équilibré et par ailleurs nos baisses de
d'impôts en effet elles sont plus
équilibrées et plus justes au sens où en
particulier les classes modestes hein et
en particulier avec la taxe d'habitation
vont bénéficier de de cette baisse
d'impôt ouais la mesure de d'Emmanuel
Macron ne vise tout simplement qu'à
transférer une partie de l'impôt sur la
fortune sur les classes moyennes en
réalité c'est de ça qui s'agit donc en
fait les avec cette réforme là les très
riches piront moins d'impôts et la
classe moyenne se verra encore
matraquer si vous pensez que les très
très très riches payent l'impôt sur la
fortune vous vous trompez parce que en
effet ils ne payent pas d'abord je vous
rappelle que l'impôt sur la fortune de
toute façon il est capé à 70 % du revenu
et ce qu'on sait on le sait en par
particulier sur par exemple madame
betancour c'est que ces gens-là ne
payent très
très non les très très riches ne payent
que très peu d'impôt sur la fortune je
parle pas des très très riches je parle
des Très
Riches elle maintient mentf d'autres
mesures par exemple sur les droits de
succession pour faciliter l'association
des entreprises mais je reviens enfin la
question de de la baisse des dépenses
pour nous on récuse un petit peu cette
logique un petit peu comptable qui
consiste à considérer que l'État c'est
un agent comm comme un autre pour les qu
effectivement il faut les recettes d'un
côté les dépenses de l'autre et par un
jeu de de de vase communicquant on fait
baisser l'un on fait baisser l'autre la
réalité c'est que l'État n'est pas un
agent comme comme un aôutre ça fait
quelques années depuis plusieurs années
déjà qu'on est dans une perspective en
tout cas d'une tentative de baisse des
dépenses on voit bien que ça entraîne
des effets procycliques qui réduisent
l'activité qui agissent sur les recettes
et qui de du coup nous entraînent dans
un dans dans dans un espèce de cycle
cercle vicieux si vous voulez de baisse
des dépenses baisse des recettes baisse
des dépenses et on en sort pas c'est ça
c'est d'ailleurs la l'austérité imposée
par Bruxelles
Mathie juste ce que enfin moi j'ai lu le
programme de Marine Le Pen il y a 60
milliards ou 58 milliards de réduction
de la dépense publique oui de la dépense
publique des mauvaises dépenses publque
oui ENF n vous êtes 5 milliard alors
c'est VI que vous dit vous Metz la
retite à
60 an vous augmentz le budget de la
défense 3 % du pb mais vous faites quand
même 60 milliard d'économie quelque
chose qui
pasah si lisez bien l'économie générale
du programme vous verrez que les non
mais justement ça va les économies de
sur les dépenses sont très clairement
identifiées hein c'est les économies sur
l'immigration l'économie sur les
économies sur la fraude l'économie sur
l'Union européenne l'économie sur la
réforme territoriale l'économie sur la
réforme territoriale les trois échelons
tout ça enfin
liseztaill du coup je trouve que c'est
un peu enfin voilà vous dites d'un côté
finalement vous avez pas cet objectif
comptable de dépenses publque quand on
regarde votre cadrage vous a un objectif
comptable de réduction de dépenses
publiques alors même que vous annoncez
une rel
dépc pareil alors Vinc moi vis je
voudrais dire que on sous-estime
largement et la plupart des candidats
sous-estiment la situation actuelle de
la France sur le plan financier on a une
dette considérable de de de 1100
milliards les gens se rendent absolument
pas compte de ce que c'est et qui est
détenu surtout à 60 % par les étrangers
par des étrangers donc qui a à un moment
donné peuvent nous imposer des choses et
notamment si les taux remontent donc je
pense qu'il faut pas oublier ça il faut
pas oublier non plus l'objectif d'une
politique fiscale l'objectif de la
politique fiscale c'est quand même de
euh de mettre du carburant dans
l'économie de façon à créer des emplois
et aller vers le plein emploi ça c'est
l'objectif prioritaire parce que le
chômage on en parle pas suffisamment à
mon avis mais il faut en parler beaucoup
plus que ça dans la campagne c'est
l'objectif prioritaire de François
Fillon et l'obj le deuxième objectif
c'est de faire reculer la pauvreté la
pauvreté a augmenté ces dernières années
de façon assez considérable et il faut
faire reculer cette pauvreté et on ne
pourra pas le faire si on ne crée pas
cette richesse alors pour la TVA je je
voudrais préciser parce que tout à
l'heure ça a pas été dit mais par
rapport au produits de première
nécessité la TVA ne bougerait pas et moi
je suis pour une redéfinition des
produits de première nécessité parce que
on met aujourd'hui par exemple des sodas
dans les produits de première nécessité
alors que le soda n'a rien à y faire
donc il y a un toilettage à faire de
façon à ce que effectivement par rapport
au aux couches modestes ça ne touche pas
et qu'il a éventuellement même d'autres
produits qui soient dans les produits à
taux réduits qui ne bougeraient pas et
par contre pour le reste et pour faire
notamment payer notre protection sociale
par les importations il faut augmenter
un peu le taux de la TVA mais pardon la
la politique fiscale à elle seul ne
suffit pas c'estàdire que vous je
partage hein les objectifs que vous
citez en terme de plein emploi de
croissance et cetera mais la
problématique c'est qu'aujourd'hui vous
avez un état un état Mancha ou un état
cjat c'estd que vous avez que la
politique fiscale pour agir grosso modo
puisqueen réalité les abandons de
souveraineté successif nous nous empêche
finalement d'avoir une politique
macro-économique équilibrée en jouant
sur tous les leviers susceptible elle
seule de provoquer le le cercle vertueux
dont vous parlez donc il faut d'abord si
vous voulez un projet qui ne prévoit pas
d'abord la récupération des outils de
souveraineté pour pouvoir mettre en
œuvre une politique macro-économique
équilibrée c'est en réalité un attrap
Nigo voilà enfin c'est ce sont des
projets qui de toute façon ne verront
jamais le jour parce que on aura jamais
les outils pour les pour les appliquer
th Martin on arrive bientôt Philippe
Martin pardon au terme de ce débat
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui on peut dire et
bien qu'il y a les Français pont moins
d'impôt avec Emmanuel Macron est-ce que
ça c'est électoraliste de dire ça je
sais pas si c'est électoraliste mais si
on part du constat que il y a trop
d'impôts et que ces impôts sont injustes
oui ils vont payer moins d'impôts sur il
y a 10 milliards en effet de baisse de
dépenses de d'impôts par non sur sur les
ménages ouais Vincent de même question
pour vous avec écoute écoutez je l'ai
dit tout à l'heure effectivement il y a
il y a une volonté de baisser aussi de
10 milliards he tout à l'heure la la
réduction de la dépense publique de de
qui annoncé par Macron c'est 60
milliards mais par rapport à l'évolution
spontanée de dépenses c'est ce qu' fait
Holland c'est ce qu' fait Holland depuis
un moment 50 milliards excusez-moi les
50 milliards non c'est pas du tout le
même calcul les 50 milliards qui ont été
qui ont été fait qui ont été annoncés
par Monsieur Vals avec Monsieur Hollande
et Monsieur Macron au gouvernement
c'était une réduction aussi par par
rapport évolution spontanée ce qu'on a
jamais eu en fait on l'a jamais eu sauf
dans les collectivités locales où ça on
l'a bien eu donc nous on est pour une
vraie réduction de la dépense publique
avec des réformes parce que si on fait
pas de réforme et si on propose pas de
réforme c'est pas facile de proposer des
réformes parce que pas facile pour les
gens de l'entendre mais moi je pense
qu'il faut être réaliste par rapport à
la situation de la France et il faut
savoir où on a envie d'aller dans 10 ans
et c'est ça qu'il faut regarder Jean
Messia nous on n'est pas dans une
approche globale si vous voulez nous
ciblons la baisse des impôts les les
gens qui paiont moins d'impôts ce sont
les classes moyennes et ce sont
également les petites et moyennes
entreprises qui sont les les les deux
priorités de notre projet ouais Mathieu
plan pour conclure avec vous on voyez
dans notre sondage et bien que 30 % des
français faisaient plutôt confiance à
Emmanuel Macron pour améliorer la
situation fiscale est-ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec cet élément j'ai pas à me
prononcer savoir si effectivement je
suis d'accord ou pas là-dessus ce que je
veux dire c'est que il y a quand même
aussi un vrai toilettage à faire ne
serait-ce que sur les les allègements
par exemple des entreprises on voit
qu'on a eu les allègements Fillon on a
eu le cice le pack de responsabilité
tout ça créer aussi de l'instabilité
c'est illisible à mon avis pour les
entreprises donc il y a aussi un travail
à faire de ce côté-là et puis puis moi
je pense que effectivement on a eu C ans
d'austérité fiscale notamment pour les
ménages et qui est un geste important et
effectivement de réorienter les baisses
de fiscalité vers eux tout en essayant
de d'avoir une plus de lisibilité du
côté des entreprises ça veut pas dire il
faut supprimer les cotisations pour les
entreprises mais il faut faudrait
clarifier un peu aujourd'hui les
objectifs
[Musique]
poursuivis